[Music]
last night during election coverage
people were tweeting
that uh abc news anchor diane sawyer
seemed seemed like she was drunk here's
a quick look
but we have a projection to make without
our music we need our music many of you
are tweeting us
yeah i mean it was just
i don't know what was going on but
actually i looked into it it turns out a
lot of people covering the election last
night seemed to have been drinking
before they went on the air
you know i i'm
i still don't understand why government
don't cleveland today but if ohio and uh
i think you have a very good night for
the president united states and as we
stand here chicago sweden chicago
this is the fox news election alerts and
the close the polls have just closed
many of us loved mcgovern but there had
to be a whole
when we called it that time come to
jesus meeting vote get out there get to
the polls and cast your ballot then come
back here get some pizza or whatever you
like for happy food and stick with us
all night
and some pizza
happy food